so I think that means the answer is yes
last question today hey David would you
consider running for office maybe as a
u.s. congressman in Massachusetts this
is so funny you know I was just having a
conversation with someone in elected
office actually in the House of
Representatives about whether I have
political aspirations and I explained
that what it comes down to for me by the
way I can never be president because I
wasn't born in the United States
sometimes people asked if I would ever
run for president I there'd be no point
I can't legally be president I've sort
of pointed out I would do anything that
I believe would be the most direct path
to as much influence and impact as
possible so like for example there have
been times where I've explored running
for City Council in different places
where I've lived and what I determined
was that the amount of time required and
the relative to the amount of influence
that I might be able to have on my
community in the context of the amount
of influence and reached that the David
Pakman show had at the time made it not
logical to run for that office when it
comes to running for Congress you know
there are I think it's 13 or 14
districts here in Massachusetts there
are some members of Congress who have
been there for a while and some who have
not been there for a long time there are
some who are more vulnerable and less
vulnerable I am not at all against in
principle getting involved in primary a
an incumbent Democrat in the House of
Representatives representing
Massachusetts but it has to be the right
time and I don't want to do like a
symbolic campaign like if I were to do
it it would be because I identify an
opportunity I determined that in that
position I could have more of an
influence than via the David Pakman show
which is now on more than 200 radio and
TV stations 10 million views a month on
YouTube etc etc and I would also
actually do the due diligence of talking
to political consultants about is this
realistic because as I said the symbolic
campaign to get my name out there raise
20 grand in donations and never really
have a shot or do anything that's not
interesting to
and it wouldn't make sense to take time
off of the show in order to do that so
to go back to the question would I
consider running for office yes I would
what I consider running for US
congressman from Massachusetts sure I
would I would consider any position that
was one that would provide a platform
from which to make positive change and
improve society for as many people as
possible do I have any particular plan a
particular seat I'm looking at or have I
had any conversation beyond just this
casual conversation with a with an
elected official last week no I have not
no I have not and maybe that that's
something that would happen but the you
know the other thing is the longer I do
the show and the bigger the show gets
the bigger the opportunity cost to not
doing the show if that if that makes
sense so a lot to weigh a lot of
questions but certainly something that I
would consider we've got a great bonus
show for you today I hope that you
either become a member or a patron so
that you can get access to the bonus
show and we will have if you're not a
bonus show subscriber a whole new week
of shows coming up on Monday